adultery has existed since marriage was
invented
and so too the taboo against it
in fact infidelity has a tenacity
that marriage can only envy so much so
that this is the only commandment that
is repeated
twice in the bible once for doing it
and once just for thinking about it
so how do we reconcile what is
universally forbidden
yet universally practiced
how do we heal from an affair
desire runs deep betrayal runs deep
but it can be healed and some affairs
are death knells for relationships that
were already dying on the vine
but others will jolt us into new
possibilities
the fact is the majority of couples who
have experienced the fair stay together
but some of them will merely survive and
others will actually be able to turn a
crisis into an opportunity
they'll be able to turn this into a
generative experience and i'm actually
thinking even more so for the deceived
partner
who will often say you think i didn't
want more
but i'm not the one who did it but now
that the affair is exposed
they too get to claim more and they no
longer have to
uphold the status quo that may not have
been working for them that well either
i've noticed that a lot of couples in
the immediate aftermath of an affair
because of this new disorder that may
actually lead to a new order
will have depths of conversations with
honesty and openness that they haven't
had in decades
and partners who are sexually
indifferent find themselves suddenly so
lustfully variations they don't know
where it's coming from
something about the fear of loss will
rekindle desire
and make way for an entirely new kind of
truth
now you've listened to me and i know
what you're thinking
she has a french accent she must be
pro-affair
so you're wrong i am not french
and i'm not pro-affair i look at affairs
from a dual perspective
hurt and betrayal on one side
growth and self-discovery on the other
what it did to you and what it meant for
me
and so when a couple comes to me in the
aftermath
of an affair that has been revealed
i will often tell them this today
in the west most of us are gonna have
two or three relationships or marriages
and some of us are gonna do it with the
same person
your first marriage is over would you
like to create a second one
together